Hey YouTubers, it's Charlie. The BBC just
dropped a brand new TV trailer for the
Doctor Who Christmas Special.
We got a much better look at the aliens
and we got some details about the special
itself.
New round of the giveaway starts now. It's a $20 Amazon gift card. All you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video.
I'll name a winner whenever I post my next
Doctor Who video next week.
The official synopsis reads "Four crew
members of an ice cap polar base
Ashley Carter, Bellows, Professor Albert
and Shona are under attack from the alien
Kantrofarri.
Fortunately for them help is on the way.
But desperate though their situation is,
how willing will they be to accept one
rescuer who arrives in a police box
and another who turns up on a sleigh
pulled by flying reindeer."
And then there's the quote listed "It's
Christmas Day, it's the North Pole,
and you're dying. Who you gonna call?" So these obviously
are the Kantrofarri. The real question is
is why does the Doctor need Clara's help?
It does seem like a very the Doctor
saves Christmas with the help of Santa
Claus
and Clara. So Steven Moffat wrote the special. He called it "Scary, tense
and claustrophobic. The Thing meets
Miracle on 34th Street.
It's certainly the strangest bloody
thing I've ever written."
So that gives you an idea. It's going to be a really weird tale about digging things out of the ice,
the aliens, and getting people to believe
in Santa Claus, like the idea of the myth
of Santa Claus. They did that with Robin
Hood earlier this year, you know, is he real,
is he not real? Is the Doctor real, is he not real as seen from Clara's perspective.
Obviously the Doctor believes he's real but
I always loved that moment, there was that moment in
Robin Hood where he wasn't quite sure.
Santa is the one that actually came for
Clara first, the Doctor swooped in later.
This is a better shot of that base at the
North Pole. I'll be interested to see how
they deal with the myth about Santa's
workshop being at the North Pole,
if they try to integrate that into this
North Pole base because it seems like
the team that's there
has nothing to do with Santa. It's
hard to tell from this shot but the
Kantrofarri actually look like they're
wearing uniforms
so either they're converted people or they got
dug out of the ice
and they've just been dethawing. Note to self, if you ever find an alien spacecraft buried in
the ice
do not dig it up or any aliens for that
matter.
We do have the names of the main cast
members, the official character names.
Nick Frost we know is Santa Claus, obviously. Michael Troughton, the son of the second
Doctor is Professor Albert.
Maureen Beattie is Bellows. Faye Marsay
is Shona. Natalie Gumede is Ashley Carter. Nathan McMullen
is Wolf and Dan Starkey, obviously, is Ian.
But they're the main cast so I would
assume anyone else that does not appear on this
cast list and is secondary character
is redshirt status. But usually Moffat picks
someone off pretty quickly.
To be fair the aliens would not be a
threat if someone didn't die right away.
I just love this shot of Nick Frost
and Strax just swaggering in,
just a giant gaping hole in the side of
the research base, no big deal.
Just Santa Claus and his elves. It is so
bizarre seeing Dan Starkey without his
makeup on.
So Clara and the blackboard here, "You are dying." It could be foreshadowing for her
or for the people at the research base.
Santa implied that her belief in him was
actually a really big deal so that
somehow might be tied to her survival. Here's
actually a much better shot of the
Kantrofarri
standing up. it almost looks like you can
see the skin of a human neck underneath that
giant head.
So it's possible that the Kantrofarri are
converting people at the research base.
So just to address Clara Oswald. Steven
Moffat did say that they would address
what happened in Death in Heaven,
like the death of Danny and her leaving
the Doctor
like it would be part of the episode,
like a big part of the story. Jenna
Coleman has been back and forth about
whether or not she's leaving.
Right now it looks like she's going to
stay on for at least 4 or 5 episodes of
Series 9.
Peter Capaldi has been reported as
signing on for Series 9 and 10.
I've only seen that from one news
publication so look forward to more news
from that after the Christmas Special
or at least around the Christmas Special.
The BBC will probably make an official
announcement.
Nick Frost has said a couple things about
his character. He said
"My Santa is cross, mean, and curt as well
as cheery and funny
which seems kinda all over the place,
it seems a little bipolar. He's got a little bit
of Robert De Niro
in Mean Streets and he has a history with
the Doctor.
It's not talked about exactly but they
have a beef with each other
from way back." I just love that idea. It
also means that Santa is really long lived
although he's not a Time Lord, there have
been a lot of theories about that.
I don't think he's a Time Lord, I think they'll
explain it some other way. Moffat doesn't
always explain everything
in great detail, like he doesn't always
get really particular with the details.
So once we actually see it we can decide
whether or not he's a Time Lord if they
don't actually show him operating a
TARDIS or anything like that.
Presumably he's flying that sleigh which does
not look like Time Lord technology
so we'll see.
So I know everyone's asking about bonus videos for the Christmas Special, I'm gonna start
posting a couple bonus videos starting
next week so when we get within that
two-week window
of the actual special itself I'll start posting
during the week. So
it's gonna be a lot of fun, I'm really
excited. The way they describe it is
it's going to be this
one of the weirdest Christmas Specials
ever. So I'm really looking forward to it.
But if you guys are watching on your mobile
phone or on a tablet you can click up here now,
there's new mobile links.
It's the same as the links over here. But click here
for all my other Doctor Who bonus videos
and click here to learn all about the
Sherlock Christmas Special. That's right,
I will be doing some Sherlock bonus videos
when we get closer to Christmas.
Thank you so much for watching so I will see
you guys tonight. High fives.